This is from the second book,
but the only spoiler in it is that my main character is an astronaut at this
point,
which I trust is not a spoiler since the title of the series is the lady
astronauts series.
Um,
so you know,
uh,
so everything is ruined now.
Um,
so this is from the faded sky.
Uh,
and part of the reason that I'm reading this section is because it takes place
in the neutral buoyancy lab.
And I actually got to go to the neutral buoyancy lab,
uh,
and watch a full Dev run development run,
um,
with an astronaut.
And the astronauts,
uh,
Chell Lindgrin said,
you know,
when he was inviting me,
it's like,
do you want to,
do you want to come and watch me do this?
Um,
you'll be able to watch the suit up and everything.
You can hang out all day,
but you probably won't want to cause it will be really boring.
And I'm like,
so chill.
You know how I'm a professional puppeteer.
Next time you're in New York,
if you want to go hang out on sesame street,
let me know.
But you probably won't want to hang out all day because it will be really
boring.
He acknowledged I had a point
and spoiler not boring at all.
So,
um,
so I also do the audio books.
Uh,
and what you're going to see aside from the presence of a microphone and
headphones is actually the way I recorded this,
uh,
in the studio.
The thing about wearing a space suit on earth is that it's designed for lower
gravity.
Even being in the neutral buoyancy labs pool didn't change the fact that gravity
pulled at me.
Sure it didn't sly,
it didn't pull it the suit.
But inside I slid around every time I changed orientation as a woman,
I was smaller than the men the suits had been designed for.
So I had to wear a pad and around my hips to sorta wedge me in.
Ms kept the air bubbles surrounding me inside the suit distributed evenly,
allowing me to move from horizontal to vertical over the course of the NBL run
without fight and gravity without the pattern and the air bubble acted like a
giant beach ball strapped my stomach always wanting to be pointed up toward the
surface.
It made it difficult to roll in any other way,
direction and truth.
Having an air bubble inside of the suit wouldn't be a problem in space.
Matt,
the NBL was where people decided if you had what it took to do a spacewalk,
so neither I nor any of the other women would complain.
No Sir.
Everything was splinted and we were a happy to be in the pool.
I hung sideways in the water with the fiberglass shell digging into my armpit,
my neck burn from holding my head up inside my helmet.
My fingers ached from forcing my stiff gloves to close on the edge of the solar
panel.
We were practicing repairing with the suits pressurized to 4.9 PSI above ambient
pressure.
Every movement felt like working against a heavy duty spring.
It wasn't exactly like in a vacuum,
but it gave us a sense of how exhausting it would be.
A wrinkle in my glove felt like a metal wire across my knuckle as the pressure
made it rigid,
but if you asked me how I was doing,
I would be so very,
very chipper on the other side of the panel.
Hafael Avellino swore in Portuguese as his gloves slid off the ranch.
Our support divers is floated in a pod around us and let the ranch drift away.
Their job was to keep us safe and ours was to learn how to do repairs in zero g
tethered to the mws or many workstation on the chest of a space suit.
The ranch didn't go far,
but it was still a pain reeling it in as how fails.
Curses buzzed over the comm.
I grinned inside my helmet.
I'm beginning to understand why Parker is learning Portuguese on my left and
slightly below me.
Leonard helped me study the panel is huff Ale,
got the wrench back into place.
We all need more languages to square it.
I've just got Latin and Greek and there's only so far that can take you.
Oh yeah.
What's a Latin class like?
I'll fail.
Place the wrench again and reseeded his feet and the foot restraints secured in
a wif mechanical receptor on the mockup Stereo of our craft.
What does with stand for no idea?
At a certain point,
the acronyms just become the name with was widget interface.
Forget about it.
That's the actual answer that I got from an actual astronaut.
When I asked what that meant,
one of the mini benefits to building the ships in space was that we didn't have
to worry about aerodynamics.
Whiffs and grips covered the surface of the ship.
Half a hills wrench slipped again,
but he didn't lose his grasp because I could use some more curses right now.
Leonard hesitated and then chuckled.
Actually,
most of them aren't things I can say in mixed company,
please.
I braced against my foot.
Restrain is how fail.
Finally they got the ranch engaged.
Say The fucking Latin.
That got a huge laugh from both men though.
My face flame did.
Having said it,
thank God the helmets meant they couldn't see me clearly.
Even for a laugh.
That kind of language was not in my normal vocabulary and then predictably Jason
Sour I sim soup Juju or crackled into our ears language vomit butoh can carve in
May.
Leonard intoned with great solemnity.
Hava hills had came up in his helmet that is close enough to Portuguese that I
actually understood it.
Mostly gentlemen,
lady for a guy from Chicago.
It,
it could be so prim.
Sometimes we have visitors and they are listening here.
The three of us exchanged glances and Hafael rolled his eyes.
What language do they speak?
English with the microphone.
We could just make out someone talking in the background but not the substance
of the conversation and the same soups response was sharp and biting.
No,
bringing them up early as absolutely out of the and then it might cut off.
What did that been through the water?
I couldn't see what the guys thought,
so I just stood there bracing the panel.
It wasn't like the sim soup to leave his mic open,
which raised the question of what sort of visitors would distract him that badly
to say nothing of who might be asking us to come out of the NBL early.
Half a hell got that bolt tightened down and we moved on as a unit to extend the
next piece of the panel.
This was the fourth time we'd done this particular NBL run and each time we got
a little faster.
Of course it wasn't likely that I would be the one doing the Eva,
but the IAC believed in over preparation and after my late start I supported
them in that.
Besides it would make being the ivy person,
the intro vehicular person easier if I knew what they were facing,
given the communication lags we would have during the mission.
We couldn't rely on ground control to coach the team.
In every scenario.
Folks,
we're going to stand down on extending the array and the Nissim soups voice
crackled.
Then the microphone rustled and shifted as though he were handing it off with
loaded underwater with the constant hum of fans and sound of our own breath.
His company then director Clemens came on the calm.
We have to pull dr flood route,
but Dr. York and Captain Avellino will stay and walks through the cleanup.
Dr Flattery,
I need you out of the Pool Pronto.
Leonard drew breath as if he was going to argue then snapped his mouth shut so
hard.
I heard his teeth click.
No Sir.
So you're top side.
I am ashamed to say that my primary emotion was not curiosity or even annoyance
than our training had been interrupted,
but relief that for once it wasn't me.
Leonard turned from us and let the divers drag him through the water to the
platform that would carry him to the surface.
Hafael and I floated in the pool.
I let my head slumped against the side of my helmet and closed my eyes for a
moment.
While our support divers reconfigured the ship mock up to the end state of the
run.
It took so long to get into the suits that it made sense to let us practice the
end of the run.
While we were already down there,
I kept listening to the comm waiting for sal to tell us something else about
what was happening with Leonard.
When the divers were ready for us,
we started the run again,
but kept conversation,
do the bare minimum required for work.
After I got over my relief,
I had a huge case of what the devil is going on.
I'm in pulled out of training before,
but not an actual NBL run,
not required.
Restarting the entire thing,
which was expensive and an enormous loss of training time.
Heck,
the way the suits were configured,
it took two days just to replace a crew member short of a medical emergency or
equipment malfunction,
nothing interrupted and NBL run.
So what would Clemons think was so important that it couldn't wait and why
weren't they telling us?
The lift out of the MDLS pool took ages as my helmet breach the surface of the
water,
the stand,
I was strapped to supported the hundred and 40 kilograms of my suit.
Trying to walk and a full suit in earth.
Gravity is not possible.
Even just the bottoms are like,
well,
it's like wearing diapers in a snow suit made of lead.
The robot in lost in space had more grace than we did.
I hung in the dawning stand as a swarm of suit.
Tex helped us to disrobe when you want answers,
everything seems to take longer and waited for my soup tech to remove the tools
and tethers and like leg weights.
As much as I wanted to rush her,
everything had to be done in sequence.
On the other side of the donning stand,
ah,
fail was going through the same slow careful extraction from his space suit.
It was like my suit tech was moving underwater as she opened the valve on the
side to depressurize the space suit down to below one.
Sure.
I can talk now and she could hear me along with everyone else listening on my
coms,
my suit tech,
but her hands on the release of my gloves breathe out.
I exhaled is the remaining bit of Delta pressure popped released when she popped
the glove.
It wasn't likely that I would blow out a lung,
but over precautions where the ISC stock and trade the suit settled around me as
she pulled the glove away.
Then finally she reached for the helmet.
The moment I,
it was off,
I asked her what's going on.
She glanced over her shoulder at the control room.
We were told to get you cleaned up as fast as possible.
It's the FBI.
Thanks for that reading.
Sure.
Um,
so,
uh,
one of the first questions I wanted to ask you about since this was,
looking back at kind of an alternate history of the space race,
um,
how much research did you end up doing?
Um,
what was your favorite bit of research and was there a piece that just didn't
make the cut?
Okay.
Oh,
um,
so researching,
this was a lot of reading autobiographies.
Uh,
I focused mostly on the mercury and Apollo era.
and then also I looked at,
uh,
the WASPS,
the women Air Force or the Women Air Service pilots from World War II.
Um,
so those were kind of the primary areas of,
of book research.
The other thing that I did was that I lined up some topic experts.
So I had,
um,
I had,
uh,
Steven grenade.
I intro,
uh,
used him as my science consultant for the whole thing.
He read the entire book.
He's a,
does rocket science.
He does robotics.
Uh,
he was a chemistry major,
like,
um,
Nasa Goddard,
he's,
he's done all of that.
Uh,
then I also had a couple of astronauts Chell Lindgren,
um,
who was in the one who invited me to the NBL and Katie Coleman,
who's a shuttle era astronaut and an actual lady astronaut.
Uh,
she's the one who gave me a lot of the details about having to put the padding
around the hips in the NBL,
which is something the guys don't have to do.
Um,
and uh,
and then also had people,
um,
like I had a,
uh,
Judaism a consultant,
um,
because my main character is Jewish and I am not.
Uh,
so it was a,
lots of,
lots of that sort of reading.
Um,
one of the things that I would say was kind of surprising was I was,
I was aware of the mercury 13 and kind of like very loose.
Like I think someone has mentioned something about it at some point,
uh,
but I didn't actually know really anything about them.
Um,
and so the mercury 13 where people who were women who were put through the,
uh,
the mercury testing program,
um,
to see how women performed and the roof,
some of the things that I was surprised by was that we actually performed better
than the guys.
Um,
and there are a couple of reasons for that.
One is that we tend to be smaller,
but also the way our circulatory system works,
partly because designed for carrying babies and things like that we handle g
force is significantly better than men.
The other thing,
and this was my favorite thing,
was when they did the stress testing,
um,
all of the women performed better than the men in the stress testing.
And the one that I was like,
oh,
well that's why.
And the delightful surprise was one of them was a mother of eight.
So I just imagine her getting into the stress testing and being like,
what?
Oh,
there's unexpected noises going off.
okay.
I have to do a complex task while someone is trying to get my attention.
What happens?
Is it nap time now?
I mean,
so,
uh,
so I loved that and I,
I do,
I mentioned her in there.
I wanted to actually get her in as a major character and couldn't quite get her
in.
Um,
and there were,
there were other things that like,
uh,
one of the things that I really wanted to get into the books that I couldn't
find a spot for,
it was a astronauts do survival training.
So they send them out and they're like,
okay,
we're going to drop you in a desert or we're going to drop you in,
you know,
in this snow a wasteland.
Uh,
we'll see you in seven days,
but by,
and couldn't,
just,
could not work that in.
There was a lot of training stuff that was like,
oh,
I want this.
I want this so bad light and no space in space for the mercury pity laugh for
the mercury 13,
like,
uh,
what was the sort of conclusion from some of the research or how did they couch
like,
Yo,
thanks for showing up,
but like,
no thanks.
Uh,
so,
um,
what happened is they got through the initial testing,
they were getting ready to go into the next stage,
which required using some special equipment at NASA.
And,
uh,
went to NASA and NASA went to Lyndon Johnson and he said,
no,
absolutely not.
Uh,
and he,
so he drafted a letter saying,
let's shut this thing down.
He never sent the letter.
Um,
what the letter he sent was,
well,
of course I'll leave it up to you.
And strangely,
that meant that nothing happened.
Um,
the requirements then for who could become a astronaut shifted so that you had
to have a right around in this time.
And I'm sure it's completely coincidental,
um,
that shifted.
So you had to have so many hours as a pilot in command of a jet,
um,
which was something that only people,
military fighter pilots could have.
So it goes on to have,
they go on to have a congressional hearings,
like they fought this to continue the training,
um,
and the testing,
and they,
they go to congressional hearings and the congressional hearings are basically
lots of things like,
you know,
men go into space,
women,
women take care of the home.
Um,
and,
uh,
and other things like,
well,
you know,
of course we'd take any woman who met the qualifications and they're like,
right,
right.
So lots of things like that.
And one of the things actually that also came up in those hearings was,
uh,
so John Glenn was there and one of the women was like,
you know,
but,
but you wouldn't have qualified with the,
the,
uh,
the standards that they have now,
because when he qualified,
when they put him in there,
you know,
first,
first orbit,
their first man really,
uh,
shepard was the first up,
but Glen was the first orbit.
Um,
uh,
when,
when you did that,
they didn't have the requirement for advanced degrees and he got an advanced
degree later.
Um,
but he wouldn't have qualified.
And they're like,
well,
you did,
you know,
why,
why not want to look at equivalent things.
And the other thing was that most of the women had more flight time than any of
the astronauts did before they went in.
Uh,
because they are service,
the wasps were flying constantly.
They had a lot of them,
I think.
I think all of the mercury 13 had like over a thousand hours of flight time
clocked.
Uh,
it was,
they were very impressive pilots.
Um,
so let's take a step back for a second.
So,
uh,
we read that section of the book.
Um,
could you just talk a little bit about why you chose the particular point in
time to start?
Sure.
The series a and,
um,
what were some of the decisions around that?
Right.
So the [inaudible] series starts in 1952,
uh,
when I slam a meteor into the Chesapeake bay,
this is not a spoiler.
I literally do this on the first line of the novel.
Um,
so,
uh,
and that's my cusp point.
Uh,
there,
there is actually technically a cusp point before that,
which is that I have Dewey as the president.
Um,
because I needed the space program to be slightly more advanced.
Uh,
the reason I chose the 1950s is that this was a at which computers were women.
Um,
that that was if you said computer,
you meant someone who did math.
Uh,
and mechanical computers were not really,
I mean they,
they existed,
but they were definitely far from reliable.
So if you wanted a computer in space at that point it had to be a woman.
And what I was looking at basically was what are the things that would make
people change their mind about sending women into space,
um,
giving,
having a task that,
that was defined in that era as a woman's job,
which was computing,
um,
that,
that was one thing,
uh,
making it,
a,
um,
an extinction level event so that we had to be talking about colonies so that
we,
it's like,
you know,
and again,
one of the conversations they have in the book is like,
you know,
if you want to colony,
you kind of,
there's this component that you need there.
The guys don't house.
Maybe you want to send somebody a onetime colony,
you know.
Um,
so,
uh,
but,
but mostly it was because of the,
the computing.
Okay.
I needed technology to be at a point at which we had the ability to go into
space.
But,
um,
but before we had computers,
mechanical computers and 1952,
uh,
1952 also,
there's a short story that comes before the novels that no one in the universe
of the novels is aware of that.
And for that there needed to be a plot point that it revolved around leap year
and ms calculating something based on leap day and getting to it,
which
no one,
no one in their universe knows about,
but it was,
so that's why it's 1952 specifically and in March 3rd.
Okay.
Um,
yeah,
I mean the events of the book takes place in,
you know,
an Arrow that a lot of us are familiar with.
Right.
Um,
and one thing is a reader,
you know,
it is a psi Phi series,
but at the same time like you don't have to spend a lot of time explaining like
magical,
infinite power sources are faster than light travel or other nonsense.
Right.
Um,
how did you make choices about like,
what to go into detail on,
on the sort of like hard Saifai side versus,
you know,
the,
the story elements are the characters.
Um,
I am very sneaky about this.
Uh,
so I,
I am,
uh,
like I was an art major in college.
I'm a professional puppeteer.
I read books out loud for a living and,
and write things.
Um,
math is a,
math is a magic system as far as I'm concerned.
You know,
it's like people can do amazing things with math and I understand that
intellectually and bully for them.
Um,
so I treated it like a magic system.
One of the things that I did was to set up the rules very clearly and to
establish my character's competence right at the beginning.
Uh,
there is a scene very early on in which a Elma is trying to calculate the size
of the media because it's gone into the Chesapeake Bay.
Tried to figure out how big it was,
um,
cause she's trying to prove that the Russians could not have moved it and named
it at the,
because it is cold war and right.
Of course.
Um,
so she's trying to,
to demonstrate this and uh,
Steven grenade like gave me this very long email in which he walked me through
how this equate,
I found the equation.
I'm like,
I can tell that this equation does this thing,
but I don't understand any of the things that are actually happening here.
So he did the math,
walked me through it,
and then I just gave that to my characters.
And there's a conversation where they're throwing technical terms at each other
and you know how when you're working on something and you'll,
you'll just be like,
so,
okay man,
and a number of tools,
uh,
and you just say the occasional words out loud.
Um,
so I have my characters to do that,
which makes them sound super smart
and,
and like all of the math that they're saying out loud is correct.
Right.
Um,
and then later I can get away with the saying and then I did the calculations
and people are like,
oh,
well she totally knows what the calculations are,
obviously.
Um,
so,
so I would explain it enough to establish competence.
And then the only other times that I would explain it is if it was something
that you needed to know in order to understand something further down the line.
Um,
so like the NBL scene is basically establishing a competence in space,
right?
Um,
uh,
and also giving me the,
you know,
it's like this is what a whiff is.
So that later when the Wifi is important,
I don't have to stop and say,
well is incredibly as tense scene is happening.
Oh,
whiff by the way is a widget interface now.
Right.
I can't remember what it actually does stand for.
He,
he did tell me later,
but he had to go look it up.
Now.
The first cancer is pretty good.
It is.
Which ad interface?
I told him,
I was like,
you know,
that's going directly in the book.
He's like,
abort,
abort.
I'm like too late.
Yeah.
Well I like that.
Um,
in the book a lot of that does feel very natural and like it is introduced like
when it helps the story and uh,
yeah,
it's not,
there's,
there's no sort of longwinded section about like,
oh,
let me geek out on this particular,
yeah.
Detail.
Um,
as a reader I can tell you did a lot of fun research around that,
but it also fits so well into the story and what the characters are up to at any
given.
Awesome.
Thank you.
That's,
um,
so I find that that is very much about focus.
Like,
just providing it when the character is thinking about it naturally.
Yeah.
Um,
so let's,
uh,
let's go back and forward a little bit.
All right.
So,
um,
is it correct that the lady astronaut of Mars was the first piece you did in
this world?
No.
Oh,
okay.
Um,
it's the one that I wanted the Hugo for.
Okay.
The first piece that I wanted that I wrote in this world is a story that's
called we interrupt this broadcast.
And this is the one that I said that no one in this universe knows.
Um,
and,
and I wrote something that I called,
I jokingly call this my punch card punk universe.
Um,
uh,
and,
and the story is basically a computer engineer who has decided that a society is
going to going nowhere good and that it needs a hard reset.
And,
and the media is actually aimed and targeted,
but he dies in the blast.
So no one in this timeline knows it ever.
It's never going to be a plot point.
No one will ever know it.
As far as everyone in this universe is concerned.
It was an act of God.
But that's the first thing that I wrote.
Um,
and then lady astronaut of Mars is the second thing.
and for that I,
uh,
and that,
that's what prompted these books.
So I knew that she had this backstory.
Um,
but the book,
that story itself came up because I needed to write something for,
um,
an audio anthology called rip off where we took a famous first line and I took
the first line of wizard of Oz and then wrote this,
this story.
Um,
and that honestly,
the reason I said it in the punch card punk universe for that one was that I had
a deadline and I had this universe already created.
It's a good choice.
So I was like,
well,
I do this additional work when this is just here.
And also I like it.
Like,
I like the idea of,
um,
what we were able to do in that era.
You know,
the fact that there's,
you know,
the,
my cell phone has more computing power than we had in the entire planet.
Um,
and we sent people to the moon,
like in,
in basically these jiffy pop containers.
It's,
it's amazing.
You know,
and,
and all the calculations that were done,
you know.
Right.
Like with people just doing calculations.
So anyway,
so that's,
I don't think that answered your question.
No,
no,
no.
That was good.
I clearly have to go back and read the other,
the other piece because I have not read that one yet.
Um,
one of the things I love about the lady astronaut Marta's story is it feels very
much like it could be kind of a,
in some ways like a last chapter of like the Martian chronicles or something has
that same vibe.
You bring some Bradbury and later.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
and you know,
that was me as a fan of that stuff.
I was very excited about that.
But also it sets up this really rich world with so little,
like it is a very short story and it like has a really,
really powerful arc to it,
but it also is not heavy on detail.
Like it sets up just enough so that you can connect the dots and kind of nowhere
that,
you know,
how we count there are how the readers have those characters got there.
But then also when the,
um,
the first novel came out,
uh,
knowing that since that is set farther in the future,
then the first novel,
like I instantly cared a lot about those characters too.
Yeah.
I'm so,
I'm so glad that you felt the Bradbury vibe because that was actually a very,
that was something I thought of it as my own monster Bradbury when I was writing
it.
I'm like,
I want,
I want the Martian chronicles,
but with,
with more women,
um,
solid choice.
Yeah.
Uh,
and then it's basically,
it's like I,
I the the novels or I would like the Martian chronicles,
but with more women and people of Color,
please.
Um,
and,
uh,
just not all white dudes all the time.
It's,
um,
but I,
one of the things that was interesting about coming back to write to the,
um,
to write this original,
uh,
the,
was figuring out,
you know,
it's,
uh,
there,
there's a 40 year gap between them.
Um,
so trying to figure out who Elma was,
who Nathaniel was.
One of the things that I knew going back was that I,
I wanted their relationship to always be rock solid.
Like I did not want the marriage to ever be in jeopardy,
uh,
partly because I hate that trope a lot.
The,
Oh no,
we fight,
let me go and break up.
No,
no.
Were deeply in love again.
I'm like,
well,
that's not predictable.
Um,
so I,
I didn't want to do that.
Uh,
so I thought about those things,
um,
and,
and kind of how she would get there,
uh,
over that time.
Um,
and also,
you know,
like how,
how do you become the lady astronaut of Mars?
Like how does that become your name?
What,
what happened?
Yeah,
as a moniker.
It's a solid Monica.
It is,
it's pretty good.
Um,
yeah,
it was also fun in the bookstore to see a really,
uh,
exciting,
solid married couple as well.
And there's a lot of fun in that relationship.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
as a longtime married person,
I was like,
oh yeah.
Well,
it's good.
Anyway.
Um,
so you have also written to,
you're not exclusively a Scifi writer,
correct?
Um,
you've written in,
uh,
several different styles and genres.
Um,
how do you think about what story is right?
Or do you start with your story idea?
Do you start with a setting?
Like could you just talk a little bit about your [inaudible]?
Yeah,
so it varies from story to story.
Sometimes they'll come into it and uh,
like I know the world,
I know the setting and I have to find the character.
Sometimes I know the character and I need to figure out the world around them.
Or I have just like a scene that I,
I know that I want to write.
Um,
and so,
so then it's finding the other pieces of it.
A lot of times we liken this to gardening,
um,
but in terms of whether I do science fiction or fantasy,
these are for me,
I think of them very much as set dressing.
Um,
so there,
there are,
there's some stories that have a specific inherent structure like heist stories
have a specific inherent structure.
Romances have a specific inherent structure,
but set the,
the science fiction fantasy.
These are,
these are the set dressing.
This is the layer that goes on top of that structure because you can have a
science fiction story that is a hardcore romance and you can also have one
that's a heist novel.
Same with same with fantasy.
So what I tend to do is,
um,
I think about,
uh,
the,
the interstitial layers,
the stuff that,
the connecting tissue because what I find booth things do the science fiction
and the fantasy is they allow me to take the natural world,
tip it to the sides.
I can see all that connective tissue.
And then it also allows me to explore things that I am thinking about from the
real world,
uh,
and it allows me to talk about them without all of the emotional baggage so I
can approach them much more as a thought experiment,
which then also allows my readers to engage with it more naturally.
So what I look for then is kind of what,
what scenic design is going to support that.
It's,
it's very much the same process I go through when I'm designing a show.
It's like,
what is the aesthetic and that is going to serve this?
Is this a story that's going to be served by something that's darker and
Grittier?
Um,
is this a story that you know,
the mechanics are going to serve?
Um,
do I,
do I feel like I really need,
I really need communication to be a difficult thing,
in which case a fantasy is going to work for me much better than science
fiction.
Like all of the things from like,
why didn't you just call them on a cell phone?
The number of that,
the difficulty and disabling cell phones,
like in removing communication,
that is like one of the,
the number one problems with writing science fiction today.
It's like you have why,
why are you just not instantaneous communication?
Yeah.
It's always like having to put people in Fairday boxes.
Um,
so,
uh,
so I look at that kind of thing.
Okay.
Um,
so you,
uh,
so,
calculating stars and faded sky are the two most recent novels.
Um,
we were talking about it earlier.
Uh,
you didn't intend it to be two novels originally,
right?
Yeah,
no.
Uh,
my plan with this was to write a single novel,
um,
which I had just titled to the Lady Astronaut Book,
had no idea what it was gonna be.
There was a point where it was artimus one,
like ridiculous.
We went through 20 titles for this.
I'm not kidding.
Um,
but what happened was that my idea had been that I was going to structure it as
three novellas because the lady astronaut of Mars was a novella and I was like,
I was structured is three linkedin novellas to mimic the structure of lady
astronauts on Mars.
Um,
and I,
it part one of calculating stores is that first novella more or less untouched.
And I got,
I was,
I'd finished part two and was starting part three and it just,
it felt awful.
Uh,
and what I realized was happening was that I was having to skip emotional beats
in the second and the villa in order to save them for the third one.
So I didn't have repetition points.
And the other thing was that people read short fiction for a different thing
than they read novels for like people read short fiction for kind of a swift
emotional punch to the gut and people read novels for immersion and structuring
it is three novellas.
If I had actually published them as three independent Novellas,
I think I would have been fine.
I think it would have been able to hit all of the things I wanted to hit.
But because it was a novel form,
I was having to skip the immersion aspect of it.
I'm like,
this is not going to be satisfying for a novel reader.
Uh,
because reading these back to back like this,
uh,
so I went to my editor and I'm like,
as I said,
all of those things and um,
they were great and they let me split it into two books,
which allowed me to unpack everything.
So that part two is significantly more robust.
I was able to do a lot more of the training stuff that it was going to have to
that in the original one I had to skip.
Um,
and then could really unpack the third one to include a lot again training and
some additional things,
uh,
that otherwise I just would have had to,
to skip in order to have that quick in that you would have for,
for an Avella.
Okay.
Um,
and you've had some exciting news recently on the new books front,
right?
Yes.
So we have more lady astronaut.
Uh,
we just sold three new novels to tour.
Thank you very much.
And it's a six figure deal,
which I'm extremely excited by.
Thank you.
It's my first,
it's very exciting.
Uh,
and,
and thank you.
Thank you for the,
uh,
the sympathy clap there.
Um,
um,
uh,
as I do humble brags up here,
but thank you.
I appreciate it.
Um,
uh,
for those of you who watch good place,
I'm totally Tahani.
Uh,
oh,
fork.
Yeah.
Um,
so the,
uh,
so the first book,
or I should say the third book is called the relentless moon.
Uh,
that'll come out in 2020.
I have to turn it in in June.
Um,
which I'm exhilarated and terrified by.
uh,
but that one,
um,
is a parallel novel to the faded sky.
So it's taking place wildly while everybody,
the faded sky,
again,
I don't feel like this is a spoiler.
If you look at the cover and you know that the books are coming from a series
began with the lady astronaut of Mars,
the fact that they are going to Mars,
um,
and it's a red cover of someone's standing on the surface of Mars.
I feel like a surprise.
So safe bet there.
Anyway,
um,
so this takes place a while.
The first Mars expedition is going on.
Um,
and uh,
it focuses on Nicole Worgen and myrtle,
uh,
Lindholm who are two of the side characters in the first book,
a first and second book.
And then,
um,
basically it's like,
hello,
we are on the moon and we're trying to establish a life here in bridge parties
are difficult cause there's the gravity is so low and oh no sabotage.
Um,
so it's,
it's much more in the,
uh,
it's going to have a little bit more of a thriller vein and then some of the
other ones.
Um,
and then,
uh,
in 2021,
we have a non lady astronaut book,
which is the spare man,
uh,
which is basically,
if anyone's seen the thin man movies.
It's basically the thin man in space.
It's an interstellar cruise ship.
It's a locked room,
murder mystery,
happily married couple and their dog,
Astra.
Thank you.
Someone has,
what's the thin man movies and knows Latin.
Um,
and uh,
and then,
uh,
in 2022,
which does not sound like a real date at all.
Uh,
we will have the derivative base which picks up,
uh,
after the close of faded sky and it's Elma Nathaniel again.
Awesome.
Yeah,
congrats again.
Thanks.
It's big news.
I'm super excited by it.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I wanna talk a little bit about,
um,
some of the other stuff around being an author now.
Yeah.
Right.
So,
uh,
people probably still have some notion of the author as like,
you know,
locked in a writing cabin in the woods somewhere.
Not Inaccurate,
but you know,
you as a modern author and especially with popular fiction,
right?
Like you have a lot of interaction with people like
yeah,
probably partly as an obligation and partly for fun.
Um,
can you talk a little bit about how you balanced
outlet?
Yeah,
so one of the interesting things about being an author is that the interaction
with the public has always been part of the game.
Like the reason that,
uh,
Charles Dickens became so popular and Mark Twain was actually because they did
public readings all the time.
So that was a,
that was a lot of what drove their,
their fame and fortune.
Um,
so that,
that audience engagement,
it kind of is always there.
It's just,
it's so much easier now and harder all at the same time.
Um,
so I spend a surprising amount of time on the road,
things that they,
you do not,
they don't tell you when you sign these standard rich and famous contract that
you are going to have to be.
Thank you for the people who watch the muppets.
Um,
so you,
you kind of travel all the time.
So I'm like right now I've been home for two weeks.
Um,
before that I was,
had been on the road for 20 days.
I had been home for a day before that and then two weeks prior to that,
three days home.
And it's like,
this year has just kind of been like that.
And uh,
it is partly in a,
partly my own fault because I,
I will say yes,
I'd love to come do that thing.
I'm also partly because I have a couple of different careers running in tandem,
but,
um,
the thing that,
the thing that's nice about it is that you actually can have a career without
doing that in theory,
um,
through,
through the Internet,
uh,
which is both good and bad.
Like when I,
when I go to an event,
um,
the people who attend,
there's a certain buyin that they have to do to just show up.
So,
uh,
everybody that I'm interacting with is generally very pleasant.
You know,
I've had the occasional stalker but not terrible compared to some friends,
um,
on the Internet.
Uh,
I will have trolls come at me for reasons.
Um,
and,
and as far as I can tell,
it's just,
you know,
cause they felt like at that day.
Um,
and it's,
it,
it is interesting trying to,
that balancing act of um,
wanting to be present,
wanting to engage,
uh,
and also needing to,
preserve aspects of self.
So the thing that I talk about is that mostly what I think about is,
um,
it's not that I put on a persona,
but that I decide which parts of my life are public and which parts of my life
at private.
Like I've rarely talk about my family.
Uh,
and one of the things,
or when I do,
it's always just bragging about them.
Um,
one of the things we were talking about at lunch was,
um,
that I had had shingles,
uh,
during this 20 days of travel.
Um,
and I,
I did not want to talk about it because as soon as you talk about anything
health related on the Internet,
everyone will give you advice.
Like,
everyone,
I have a handout,
we'll have you tried.
I think at this point in my life,
I know how to deal with a hangout.
Like,
it seemed like a sensible adult,
you know,
I try.
Um,
but I also had to cancel things and I didn't want to just be like,
Oh,
I'm just canceling things.
So,
you know,
and I didn't want people to go,
she's canceling things.
Is She dying?
Because they will also go there because in fairness that is,
you know,
has happened.
Uh,
so unfortunately,
um,
so,
you know,
trying to decide how much to talk about.
So like I'll tell people I had shingles.
I do not talk about,
actually no,
in that blog post,
I did talk about the degree of pain that I was in.
Um,
but I talked about that.
What I tried to do was talk about it in terms of here's a learning experience
for you.
The show does not have to go on,
don't use my public tiers,
work ethic,
take care of yourself,
be healthy.
Um,
and so it's learning to couch things in and shift them so that I maintain
control of the conversation.
Uh,
which is,
um,
which I'm very grateful for having years of theater before.
Like I learned all of this from dealing with third graders.
Excellent.
Um,
so your uh,
you know,
uh,
there's a lot of uh,
looking back at the events of the past and the most recent novels,
right,
with
a modern lens and from the perspective of people struggling through that era.
Right.
Um,
how has the reception been to that?
Or has that sort of like attracted some of the more unsavory fan elements
because you know,
you are criticizing some of their golden ideas or
you know,
whatever nonsense yeah.
Up the thing,
the thing that uh,
like when people complain about these books,
for the most part it has been very,
very positive.
I have to say a really super positive and,
and one of the things I do deal with sexism and racism,
I deal with mental health issues,
but at the same time I feel like it's not so much it like in my head I'm not,
I'm writing a book about these things.
I'm not,
I'm writing a book about space,
but I'm not ignoring those things.
And that because so many books do we ignore them.
I think that that's what makes it feel like they are very,
very present.
These are things that affects the way characters move through the world.
And so I'm letting it affect the way that they move through the world,
but I'm not like,
for the most part,
they aren't one of those like one or two places where it's a plot point.
But for the most part it's like this is,
you know,
this is the way they move through the world.
Um,
sexism is a plot point for Elma because it's a plot point for me.
You know,
I get,
um,
when I was vice president of Sif was science fiction and fantasy writers of
America and John Scalzi was president.
I got the hate mail.
He didn't,
um,
it's not that he didn't get any,
but I would get the,
the majority of it.
So,
um,
so it's just,
it's like,
it just affects the way you move through the world.
So I was dealing with those things.
So when people complain about it,
what they complain about is,
Oh,
she's shoehorning in the social issues.
I'm like,
no,
really not.
That's just daily life.
Um,
that's,
that's the complaint that I'll get.
The other one that I'll get is a Elma.
The main character has,
um,
social anxiety disorder.
So,
you know,
she's in a plane and it's going down and she's totally fine.
You ask her to speak to a room full of people and she's like,
no,
I clearly do not have social anxiety disorder,
um,
theater,
although there are a lot of people in theater who do.
Um,
but,
uh,
but what it,
what I would get,
the other push back that I'll get is I don't believe that someone,
you know,
who gets this subset about talking to people,
like,
no one gets that upset about it.
I'm like,
yeah,
actually.
And what I have found is that people with anxiety disorders are the best people
in crises because they're like,
what?
Stress Hormones.
Come on,
bring it.
I got this.
Totally.
That's my daily life.
So one more question and then I think we've got time for Q.
And.
A.
I'm sort of on that topic of like working through a challenge.
Um,
earlier we were also talking about like how you approach writing as sort of a,
uh,
a as well as,
you know,
a creative endeavor.
Right.
Um,
uh,
could you talk a little bit about how you view that and how it related to any of
your work?
Sure.
So because I come at it from theater where,
uh,
you,
you couldn't wait for the Muse to arrive.
It's like if I'm creating something,
if I'm designing something,
I have to,
I have to be able to produce on a deadline because I,
um,
I put other people,
put other people's schedule behind it.
It's not a good team player thing to do.
So I had to learn to be creative on demand and uh,
and I also have depression.
Um,
so one of the things that I've learned is that,
um,
I can work through the three depression,
but it's incredibly difficult.
And like the,
the,
the whole create,
you know,
the creator as the depressed genius.
It's like,
I just,
every time that one comes up,
I get stabby because what happens for me is that my,
my productivity just crashes and Burns.
And,
and I mentioned briefly at lunch,
uh,
forest of memory,
which is,
um,
a novella that was on tour.com.
Um,
I wrote that during like the worst depressive episode that I have had.
I had like my,
my grandmother had died,
my cat had died unexpectedly,
like right after that,
uh,
another multiple deaths,
like right in a row,
a whole bunch of other things,
chemical imbalance,
all of that.
And,
and upon realizing finally what was happening to me,
this was the episode that finally made me admitted that I had depression and had
it all my life.
I'm in the middle of that.
I was trying to drop everything and there was this one anthology,
um,
Megatropolis Cascadia and uh,
my friend Jay Lake was the editor and it was the second book in a shared World
Anthology.
So replacing me was already going to be difficult.
Uh,
and Jay was in the process of dying from colon cancer.
Like these were,
he was terminal.
Um,
there was no way I was going to back out of this.
Like,
really this was not something I could do to my friend.
So that meant that I just had to write it and I crafted my way through that
story and people read it and they can't tell at the end of the day,
it's because I understand my craft because I understand audience storytelling
structure.
But I wrote that like there were some days that I wrote it.
I could only write three sentences.
That was my bargain with myself.
I'm like three sentences.
You can do three sentences a day.
And there's some days where I would catch fire and I could go longer.
And other days where I would write three sentences and there are a couple of
days where the three sentences were,
I hate everything.
I'm tired,
I'm going to bed.
But I sat down and I wrote them.
Um,
and,
and for me this is important because while I,
I can write that way,
but I don't enjoy it.
And my feeling now is if I am not writing and not loving it,
like if,
if I am dealing with depression,
um,
unless there is a really serious reason that I need to push through that,
that it is better for me to take care of myself and to go and,
and have some,
you know,
and,
and do self care and then come back to it when writing is,
there's still joy there because honestly,
we don't get paid enough to write when it's not fun.
Even with a six figure deal,
it's like spread out over multiple years.
Um,
but it is good to know that I can,
that,
that the,
the time that I've put in learning my craft allows me to actually do this thing.
Um,
so it is,
it's,
you know,
it's kind of boast.
It's like one of the things that I try to pay attention to when I start bogging
down is like,
am I bogging down because there's a problem with the story or my bogging down
because of something external.
And,
you know,
one of the,
you,
you handle those in different ways.
Sure.
Well Great.
Thank you.
Um,
so,
uh,
first off,
let's give a round of applause.
Thank you.
Um,
so we have a Mike over here.
Uh,
so we have time for questions.
We have like 14,
13 minutes and I will answer questions about anything.
So if you want to know,
like we didn't talk about puppetry or if you want to know about puppetry,
if you want to know about regency underwear,
uh,
if you want to know about going to NASA and the NBL,
if you want to know about trying on a space helmet,
um,
anything,
I'll talk about depression,
anything.
I will also just sit here and stare at you awkwardly.
I'd like to hear about more than a dozen typewriters.
Ah,
yes,
we have more than a dozen typewriters.
So I,
we have 19 manual typewriters.
Uh,
first of all,
I do not recommend that you collect typewriters.
They are heavy when you move.
Uh,
they are very heavy.
Um,
all of your friends hate you if you have those.
But,
uh,
our early earliest typewriter is a Blickenstaff surfer,
which is a typewriter from 1890,
or I think ours is 1893 model our 1894.
Anyway.
Um,
but it has a rotary head and it's not a Cordy keyboard.
And this cool thing about the rotary head is you,
you remember the IBM Selectrix,
um,
this predates and IBM Selectric by 70 years and uh,
and has a rotary head.
You can replace it to change the type font.
Really,
really cool.
Um,
and my favorite is the corona number three,
which was the typewriter that Hemingway took.
A I don't like,
I don't have his,
that would be awesome.
Um,
but,
uh,
the,
it's the typewriter that he used when he was doing more reporting in the first
world war and it's a folding typewriter.
So it's this thing,
it's like about that big footprint,
um,
weighs about three pounds a,
there's an aluminum one that's just stupidly light.
Uh,
and then the,
the top flips back and forth.
Um,
I have,
uh,
I have a,
the corona number three special,
which is forest green.
It's beautiful.
And it has the extended keyboard that has mathematical functions on it.
It's very cool.
I will not give you a rundown of all of the typewriters probably.
Does having 19 of them help you write faster?
You know,
it is.
Uh,
no.
Um,
but I will actually bring out the typewriter to write some times,
uh,
because it changes the rhythms with which you rate.
And there are times when just changing the medium of communication is enough to
shake the story idea loose or um,
or,
or you want that rhythm because with a manual typewriter,
because you have to hit the carriage return at the end GVH line.
There's a moment where you were doing a little composition at the end of each
line and then when you have to change the paper,
there's another moment of composition.
So it does completely change the way,
right?
Yeah.
I saw you at American writer's museum.
Oh yeah.
Pretty sure.
You gave this anecdote from your research where you found out that the,
the voice for computer and star trek is really modeled very much.
That was really surprising to me and I didn't,
but it actually,
it makes sense.
Can you say more about that and what you've learned?
Sure.
Found that bit of information.
Yeah.
All right.
So I am,
um,
some of this is me extrapolating,
so let's,
let's be clear.
Uh,
so one of the interesting things about computer voices in the United States is
that they tend by and large to be women.
Uh,
and we,
we know that the,
the people who,
um,
you know,
the people who have,
like with,
with Siri and Alexa and these other things that people have said very
specifically,
that they were thinking about the computer on Star Trek when they decide when
they assigned to the female voice and when they were thinking about it.
What's interesting is that,
you know,
Star Trek,
California,
Jpl,
jet propulsion laboratory.
So if you're doing research on space travel,
JPL is the closest place that you're going to be able to go.
Uh,
when star trek was coming out,
JPL had a policy that the only people they hired for the computer department
were women.
They did not hire him in as a policy.
Um,
so,
and,
and from early,
early days.
So the computer voices,
so that means that you've got this room full of men at a launch.
Uh,
and someone will say,
computer give us the philosophy and this one lone woman's voice will come out
and answer.
When you look at Germany,
yeah,
their computer voices tend to be male.
When you look at their early space program,
their computers tended to be men.
Now I don't know that there a,
I mean I have,
I have correlation,
which is not the same as causation,
but there certainly seems to be a pattern there where it looks very much like
life or you know,
art imitating life imitating art again.
So I find this back and forth really fascinating.
So I have a daughter who I still the scar from and I was telling you about 'em
and she's in a girl scout group that's focused,
they're doing this lego robotics focused on space exploration.
And I would love to hear your thoughts on like a topic that would be,
you know,
as you did all this research,
what would be an interesting topic that,
especially a group of girls,
you know,
and kind of those dynamics with all those challenges that were there early on.
What would be an interesting topic for them to pick as a research project?
So it's interesting,
one of the things that you make me think about when you ask that is,
um,
that when I was researching this,
I watched a number of episodes of Mr Wizzard from the 1950s.
Uh,
and then I also wound up watching some of the reboot,
uh,
that the,
the later reboot from the 70s and there was one in the 80s as well.
And the interesting thing is that the one in the 80s,
all of the science that they're having the girls do is very gendered.
It's like,
let's see about,
you know,
the science of lipstick.
Um,
I'm not kidding.
I have actually,
I don't think that was Mr Wizzard,
but I have actually seen at the science of lipstick and I,
again,
very steady.
Um,
the 1950s one is not gendered at all.
Uh,
you know,
the little girls are in skirts.
Absolutely.
But they're like,
let's look at a thermodynamics.
Um,
let's look at how we create batteries.
And they are,
he speaks to them and addresses them exactly as he would little boys.
So in terms of space flight,
I think,
you know,
space is a great topic.
And,
and that's,
uh,
in terms of something that is specifically about women,
um,
one of the things that I would say is,
is have them look at the early,
uh,
early aviation pioneers.
Um,
I,
her name is not in my head right now,
but does anyone want to make a guess about,
uh,
what year?
Uh,
the,
so first of all,
the first professional arrow not,
um,
and that should give you a clue right there.
First Professional era,
not,
uh,
was a woman.
Does anyone want to guess about what year?
This was?
18.
11,
right?
Eight,
10,
11.
This woman was employed by Napoleon for her ballooning skills.
Um,
so,
uh,
I would say,
I wish I could remember her name.
I would also say,
look at Bessie Coleman.
Bessie Coleman was the first African American woman,
a pilot.
Um,
it was not legal for her to be a pilot in the United States.
She couldn't get a license.
And this is in 19,
I think 19,
I want to say 1911,
19,
12.
Very,
very early.
Um,
so she,
the only place that she could get a license to fly was in Paris.
So she taught herself French,
went to France,
got the pilot's license,
came back.
Um,
so looking at,
at the early pioneers of,
I think they are the ones who often are most written out of history because
we've had the most time to write them out of history.
Um,
so I would look at at those,
there's a great book called the Black Wings,
which is about,
um,
African American aviation that,
that talks about Bessie Coleman.
Um,
I would also say,
uh,
promised the moon,
which is the,
uh,
the story of the mercury.
13 women.
Uh,
there's a good documentary about them.
so mercury 13 is also like,
what would,
what would space look like if that program hadn't been shut down?
I think about this all the time.
I'm interested in kind of like the releasing release timing between a
calculating sky and um,
calculating stars and getting and [inaudible] which are only like three months
apart,
release dates,
not even three months.
And uh,
uh,
you know,
my wife,
just red Marine Johnson's most recent book only to discover that it's really
half a book and that the rest of the thriller is still not yet to be released.
What was your sort of like thought process behind like,
let's get that out in this timeframe and not wait a six months or whatever.
So calculating stars came out July 3rd,
faded sky came out August 21st,
which is very fast.
Um,
my basic thought process on that was that my publisher said,
would you like to do this thing?
And I said,
yes,
I would like to do that thing.
Uh,
the reason that this is a,
uh,
an interesting publishing strategy to try when you have an author who can turn
to books out that fast.
Um,
I wrote the second book in like six months,
which is very fast for hard science fiction.
Um,
the reason is because there is a known,
a known phenomenon that when the first book in a series comes out,
there's a,
there's a bump.
Like I,
you know,
there's a,
there's something we call the series death spiral.
So the fifth book in my series did not sell as well as the first book by a lot.
But the moment I have a book come out in a new series,
there's a bump and we know that.
So,
so you want,
you want new books coming out.
And then we also know that a lot of people are completed.
They will wait until an entire series is finished before they buy any of them.
And when the last book comes out,
there's a bump in the sales of the first book.
So if you can get both of them coming out within about a month of each other,
you have both of those phenomena happening at the same time and the book sells
significantly better.
Um,
so that's basically,
that was the experiment that they wanted to try and it has worked.
Like when I look at the diagram of my book sales,
it's like these books are doing very nicely and then,
and then calculating stars happens and it's way up here.
Uh,
so it definitely worked.
Um,
there's also a number of other things that are happening with calculating stars,
bringing out a space book the same year as the 60th anniversary of NASA and the
year before the 50th anniversary of Apollo.
There's a lot of,
um,
the,
the timing is good.
I hit Zeitgeists as well,
but that's why they wanted to bring them out back to back like that.
And as a reader,
it was so exciting to get to the end of the first book and go,
Oh,
I only have to wait the shorter amount of time.
Yeah.
Uh,
the,
the other thing that we did not think through was,
or when I said,
yes,
that sounds great,
was that it meant that I had to do all that promotion as well,
because usually you promote the first book for about two weeks before it comes
out.
Then there's another two weeks of Rah Rah,
a new book when they're coming out and back to back.
It's just basically like just promotion all the time,
which was,
I mean,
fun.
It's a good problem to have,
but whoa.
Was not expecting it.
Sure.
Well,
thanks again for coming on and for the reading and for adding us to your
promotional docket with,
thank you for being in the city.
I live in.
Well,
great.
Thanks a lot,
Mary.
Robinet.